mind cm à très forte dans les soldes et
une équipe vraiment dynamique ça ça vaut
de l'or il offre plein de formation de
choses comme ça pour aider les artisans
dans cette période un peu compliquée
sont là et plus que lapointe
boulanger céramiste boucher fleuriste
plombier couvreur car hagist coiffeurs
esthéticiennes taxi photographe
bijoutier cordonnier déménageurs vous
n'êtes plus de 28000 835 artisans
installés sur le département
à vous tous vous former la première
entreprise de l'essonne vous constituez
l'économie de proximité essentiel à la
vie de tous et des quartiers vous êtes
les acteurs majeurs de la consommation
locale et responsable vous imaginez et
mettez en oeuvre des solutions pour
satisfaire la demande des clients et
vous évoluer au gré des innovations vous
former les jeunes en apprentissage et
transmettez vos précieux savoir-faire
pour leur offrir un avenir professionnel
l'acm à essonne conseil accompagne et
suit les artisans et futurs artisans
dans leurs projets de création et de
développement
j'ai voulu créer ma micro-entreprise ça
a été compliqué parce que j'étais dans
le vague
totalement j'ai appelé la chambre des
métiers et en trois jours dont ils ont
été très efficaces
j'ai eu un rendez vous aujourd'hui même
et ça a duré à peu près 30 minutes
maman étant fleurissent depuis plus de
35 ans elle m'a transmis sa passion le
métier de fleuriste je l'avais dit entre
les mains ces stages création
d'entreprise que j'ai fait avec l'acm a
permis de répondre à beaucoup de
questions que j'avais sur le pont vue
gestion de l'entreprise
j'ai mon ca pg très vite monter
l'entreprise ma rigueur règlement
céramique la formation d'installation à
l'entreprise était obligatoire pour moi
c'était essentiel d'abord d'aller suivre
ces trois jours là pour me sentir plus
armé en termes de gestion en termes de
droit j'ai découvert là bas un réseau de
gens disponibles pour vous orientez vous
guider au mieux de manière à ce que
votre projet professionnel soit
aboutisse
organisme de formation là c'est ma
essonne propose une offre sur mesure
pour répondre à tous les besoins des
artisans et de leur équipe
je pense qu'un photographe s'est d'abord
c'est d'abord un artisan on façonne on
fabrique on crée moi je cherchais à me
former sur tous les réseaux sociaux ce
qui était intéressant c'est que ça a
permis de se remettre en question de
voir façon de travailler plus que de
créer du réseau c'est plus créer du lien
lorsqu'on est à inscrire en tant
qu'artisans l'acm a donc on est porteur
de projet la série mais nous avons pas
avec des petits mots durs dans
l'informatique de la comptabilité on a
des langues
il me manquait une formation complète en
fait est artisan c est un très bon
technicien mais j'avais pas toute la
partie comptabilité gestion j'ai eu vent
qui avait donc une licence
professionnelle avait classé m1 et le
cnam
je suis inscrite pour faire une licence
professionnelle des métiers de
l'entrepreneuriat ça m'a permis en fait
donc de faire des réflexions son
entreprise en de savoir qui a été les
points à travailler et ça me permet
aussi de sortir de mon isolement acteurs
du développement économique local
la sema et saône déploie ses compétences
et ses actions dans les territoires avec
l'appui des collectivités
je fais des savons depuis depuis
maintenant 14 ans parce que je voulais
pour des produits propres pour mes
enfants travaillent avec des produits
très locaux j'ai aussi pas mal de
clients de plus en plus de particuliers
maintenant la gîte j'ai fait un click
and collect pour le pour le mois de
décembre
je suis esthéticienne cosméticienne
masseuse j'exerce depuis 20 ans chez moi
ce que je recherchais être là pour les
gens apporter du bien-être et faire mon
métier au mieux les cm à c'est un
soutien dès qu'on a des questions dès
qu'on a des soucis dès qu'on a des
interrogations il suffit de les
contacter
ils ont toujours toujours des solutions
moi je déclassé masse est un vrai
soutien
l'acm à essonne multiplie les
initiatives pour défendre les intérêts
de l'artisanat et donner le maximum de
visibilité aux artisans on l'appelle au
maître artisan c'est l'évolution du
titre de l'artisan j'ai pu l'obtenir en
partie du barça la scène qui m'a aidé
dans cette démarche là et ça ça
récompense bas toutes mes années de
travail de concours remporté deux
formations et surtout le ça me permet de
valoriser notre échec depuis 10 16 ans
je suis artisan couvreur est aujourd'hui
maître artisan la différence entre un
artisan est un maître artisan déjà ce
sont ses compétences pour moi c'est un
signe de confiance et de qualité pour
l'écrire
vous avez des questions l'acm est là
elle vous suit elle vous répond il
répond très vite au tac au tac
quelle que soit la question même si
c'est pas eux qui doivent nous donner la
réponse
il nous oriente sur un organisme sur une
personne qui elle est compétente c'est
pas un parcours facile c'est pas un
parcours tranquille mais c'est
passionnant
c'est un travail très solitaire ce qu'on
est tous dans nos ateliers justement
qu'on est en salle ont ensemble
déjà ça fait du bien de se retrouver
dans ton le public j'ai eu le plaisir
d'être aidés dans la sélection de la
fête de la création des métiers d'art de
saint jean de beauregard auquel je
postulais depuis nombreuses années comme
on est nombreux dans le bijou cd
toujours difficile de rentrer et donc
j'ai pu le faire pendant pas mal
d'années un peu grâce à la sem a quand
même et puis j'ai fait une formation
également la sema sur comment présenter
son stand pour revaloriser son son
travail
2020 va être une année compliquée pour
les artisans
nous savons à quel point nombre d'entre
nous ont souffert de la crise beaucoup
se sont montrés inventifs et solidaires
je suis fier d'appartenir à cette belle
famille qu'est l'artisanat et de la
représenter en essonne une famille qui
s'agrandit et qui pèse de plus en plus
dans le paysage économique territoriale
pour être au plus près de vos besoins là
c'est mason adapte sans cesse ses
services nous modernisons nos pratiques
d'accompagnement et de formation des
artisans nous renforçons notre action
dans les territoires pour accroître la
visibilité de l'artisanat et défendre
vos intérêts en 2021
les chambres de métiers francilienne
n'en formeront plus qu'une l'acm à d'île
de france
ce changement structurel vise à
mutualiser nos moyens et nos forces pour
renforcer notre mission sans pour autant
réduire notre action de terrain en 2021
nous déploierons des projets résolument
tournée vers le développement de
l'économie de proximité avec la charte
consommer local consommer artisanale
avec l'annuaire mon artisan 91 avec la
poursuite de la digitalisation de nos
services et le parcours croissance nous
serons toujours à vos côtés et vous
souhaitons une année 2021 plein de beaux
projets et de carnet de commandes bien
rempli merci de votre confiance à tous
la sema essonne avec vous 2021